yo encuentro que lo importante es
entender que la Corte Suprema agenda
temas según se recurre a ella ha habido
una obviamente oleada de temas digamoslo
así de la agenda liberal que ha sido
agendados por iniciativa ya sea del
partido demócrata en el congreso o por
la Casa Blanca pero la corte digamos no
es sencillo Responde lo que le consultan
y su criterio sí sin duda es bastante
más conservador pero dudo que eso tenga
que ver con la alineación de los jueces
o su alineamiento político ideológico
tiene más bien que ver con el hecho de
que la corte falla en función de la
jurisprudencia y tanto en Roy vs te
mencionaba el año pasado como en los
fallos de estos últimos días sobre la
acción afirmativa por decirle de alguna
manera y el caso de la la cuestión de
los de las minorías trans y gay yo creo
que la decisión se ha basado
íntegramente en la jurisprudencia y en
la posibilidad de evitar que se genere
un principio dentro de la legislación
americana que es el doble estándar no se
que la discriminación no es ni positiva
ni negativa desde el principio de la
corte sino más bien que genera un doble
estándar Y eso implica obviamente la
violación del principio de un ciudadano
un voto y Cada ciudadano igual a
cualquier otro no
y le pregunto entonces lo que bueno si
usted considera que la posición política
de los jueces no tiene que ver con sus
decisiones judiciales entonces cree que
se puede prever o no que lleguen otras
cuestiones que sean problemáticas a
nivel de que pueden recortar derechos o
libertades en los próximos meses a este
órgano judicial la otra cosa que hay que
distinguir rosa es mucho como Se informa
en términos de la agenda informativa y
cuál es en realidad el contenido de las
decisiones de la corte en Roy versus por
ejemplo la corte no canceló
absolutamente ningún derecho en términos
del aborto lo que hizo fue determinar
que la competencia sobre la decisión del
aborto no era una decisión de nivel
constitucional sino de nivel
legislaturas de cada estado fue casi
como reconocer que era una competencia
de las gobernaciones no así de el ente
constitucional No recortó ni quitó
absolutamente nada Pero ha habido una
instalación mediática muy fuerte
entiendo desde medios que tienen
claramente una cuestión de visión
ideológica liberal la corte los jueces
tienen ideología Yo veo que cada uno de
ellos tiene una lineamiento hay
demócratas ciertamente y republicanos
pero pienso que las decisiones se han
ajustado más como le digo el principio
constitucional Y si vamos a ver
politización dentro de la Corte Suprema
que yo creo que la hay hay jueces con
posiciones muy encontradas de hecho
también había una politización fuerte en
el tipo de recursos que se han
introducido y que han empezado a ser
evacuados desde la anterior año esos
recursos tienen que ver con consultar
cosas que el partido demócrata entiende
bastante bien que la corte no va a poder
fallar muy lejos de el criterio
constitucional previo de la
jurisprudencia Y entonces de todas
maneras las meten porque estamos en año
preelectoral y ellos necesitan que estos
temas se para poder Iniciar una campaña
muy pronto y le pregunto a Erick para
los que pues no estamos tan habituados a
este a conocer los detalles de este
funcionamiento si esto no responde a una
cuestión de ideología de los jueces Cómo
se Explica que una sentencia
aparezca en la corte constitucional
afap permitiendo el aborto en todo el
territorio como fue Robert y que se
derogue de décadas más tarde bien ha
sido la misma institución la que ha
revisado su decisión y por supuesto hay
una correlación de fuerzas que implica
determinar que probablemente es más
fácil creer que se debe al número de
jueces republicanos versos conservadores
pero el principio y la fundamentación
jurídica del fallo de la corte que no ha
sido para nada atendido por los medios
específicamente por lo que se denomina
hoy por hoy los medios alineados al
estado es el hecho de que en el fondo
los las libertades y las competencias
siguen prevaleciendo solamente que son
las legislaturas estatales la que las
que deciden Entonces pienso yo que lo
importante va a ser encontrar en el
criterio de la corte un factor libre de
la politización que está en ambos lados
en el legislativo y también en el poder
judicial